i missed you guys yeah me too i kept i
kept doing things and being like i
wonder what they would think of this
thing that i haven't been able to speak
to them about
because we had a week off you might have
said that we were doing them all last
week just waiting for my
uh my my link to be you know let me into
the room and no one ever let me in
what did you guys get i was here tuesday
by the way i just waited for a long time
and avoid
exactly speak to yourself a lot of the
time yeah i've been uh i guess i
spent most of my break for some reason
playing very difficult 90s video games
so i just finished doom 1 on
ultraviolet because it was called
ultraviolet on that game not ultra
violence and crash bandicoot i did the
hardest two levels on crash bandicoot
i don't know what specifically it was
about this break that made me go let me
just play
some really difficult 90s games but my
guess is that it's comfort in childhood
but i'm not sure that's mostly what i
got up to what do you guys been up to
mikey befell what have i been up to i've
been
other than replacing me oh yeah well
that's that's my that's my i've been
trying not to code that's been my main
job this christmas and i
failed in the last couple of days
because i've yeah i've started playing
with some procedure generation stuff but
yeah um
no we've honestly we've we've honestly
just been on like zoom calls all the
time and
talking to people and doing the
christmas thing watching them up it's
christmas carol you know all the
essential
kind of steps yeah like genuinely like a
super boring christmas to be completely
honest but i think that's kind of
probably been
most people's experience um and yeah and
reading the comments on the last video
we put up that was the other thing i was
doing this christmas just going oh god
i didn't read many of them who who
discovered the show for the first time
and were so
outraged that's why i was writing them i
was like they don't know who we are
they're never going to watch the show
again
carry yourselves home whatever good
stuff good
oh we we uh yeah we were attracted a
whole new audience
we had a massive audience and they all
hated us it was great
yeah again i didn't read most of it it's
just because we said things about
cyberpunk so again i did not read most
of it so i don't actually know i was
like i'm out
um but we also recorded it like before
half the stuff correct
you're angry about what happened yeah i
can't believe you didn't talk about this
and i was like well a we didn't know and
b it's not our jobs to know if you want
or people who believe it want to be
informed just go watch actual
journalists
it's not none of our jobs at this point
it was the two-fold
it was the it was the people well i
guess three bring this up by the way i
feel like i've really liked it
already no it was it was delightful
because it was
the people who were filled with hatred
in the comments were simultaneously
not happy that we were report that we
weren't discussing things that had
happened after
the conversation as you just said but
second it was also
um this constant like you guys are just
a bunch of shills
being paid by cdpr which i which i loved
and what do you guys work in the games
industry yeah exactly
and then on top of that the notion that
just the total
obliviousness to the format of us just
talking and so it was like oh my god 40
minutes of [ __ ] before they talk
about cyberpunk
and i was like the because i brought up
cyberpunk so many times that when i was
like i'll call it let's try to talk
about cyberpunk because the point is
that we kept trying to and then getting
off track
like this is clickbait i was like
actually this one's quite accurate i did
a pretty good job with this one they're
really difficult
i love being called a shell mail real
quick for uh
my check from cdpr and see if that
because it hasn't been so yeah i
actually didn't get one um and it's one
of my favorite things is people being
like how much should they pay you to be
like a couple of grand actually
yeah no i openly did get paid so uh you
you've known that from the start
the bigger story would be you appearing
in the game and having not been paid
exactly yeah that would have been that
would have been a problem yeah
yeah now glad glad to have been paid uh
they were lovely to work with
not revenue therefore a shill
we're bringing back ethics and games
journalism apparently not i keep being
like i'm not
talking about it i'm not doing it and
then people are upset that i'm not doing
it i'm like i don't understand how you
aren't grasping
the point of what i'm anyway we could
talk about this for forever but
it seems so simple to me to be like i
worked on this thing and that's why i'm
not talking about it i will not talk
about any
santa monica studios game i will not
talk about any game i ever work on
and uh it is odd to have people want me
to i'm like just go to other sources for
that why would you even want me to be
the person who talks about it
seems like a bad idea out of the four
people on here
three people get to talk about the games
that they're working on
sure yes right no
it doesn't work that way two me and
austin and then only
yeah we need to start a project where
austin you need to we need to like do
something that we can talk about on the
show
we'll put you you guys involved as well
we need to make up a game just so we
have something to talk about
i mean because you you guys would be in
embargo hell for
i i'd be i'd be overjoyed too but you're
you're actively
you're actively replacing i'm doing
everything i can to get the composer out
there
greg miller yeah yeah it's true that's
at least
that's at least another human i was
replacing myself you could probably
probably play a piano we could probably
get like some greg miller music in the
next game we can
just make the whole thing look i'll
start i'll i'll take off my glasses
i'll do i'll do a performance right now
you're not wearing glasses
he's already he's he's great about
actors he's got the props
well done well done i just think
immediately of course i believed him i
did do it well
i was there i was there in the moment
yeah i was with him
how was your christmas troy man mine was
great i
i i came to the realization that this
year
santa exists for the parents
it doesn't exist for the kids kids don't
care it's like wherever
the [ __ ] comes from give it to me
i don't care if a dude breaks into my
house to give it to me i don't care if
it's bomb
dad whatever especially like traveler
was two and he's like i don't care
the funny thing is he looked stone cold
in the eye and said
i don't father actually i don't care
oddly enough
i got him three pairs of jordans
and well daddy thought so i do not like
this one
i do not like this one that's what i got
if i want vehicles that's what he wanted
did you hand them back and said
i beg your pardon you [ __ ] do like
you put these on but
what if you just put little wheels on
the bottom of them if you just put
little wheels on him and tell him they
are vehicles
he looks awesome by the way you got
these kick ass he's
his shoe game is it's basically all the
stuff that i couldn't
afford as a kid or as a young adult and
i'm like hey dude can you do
daddy's vicarious living please uh that
always ends well
it's always worked out well forever
the one thing that i did i i did a
podcast earlier i don't know which is
going to come out first but i
i do want if anyone who happens to work
for
the the the post if you're a mail
carrier if you're ups
driver if you're dhl fedex amazon driver
i want to extend to you um my
gratitude and just
this is a tremendous amount of thanks
for i there's not a single package
that we needed that didn't come on time
these people worked
incredibly long hours worked their asses
off
i'd love to know the stats when all said
and done like how many
individual parcels and like the net
weight of it all or something they're
like billions of times billions of
pounds
metric tons people with real jobs man
people with real jobs yeah dude
and it was just in the gnarliest of
times
so that like a dad who forgets batteries
gets them on time there wasn't a single
package the last one i was two days
before christmas
we were out at the the dog park and
some little kid had an rc car
now for the layman that's a remote
controlled car
and this is down these are technical
ass this thing was going like 40 50
miles an hour
and it was doing flips and traveler was
transfixed on this machine so the
vehicle
on this vehicle so a traveler got an
rc car for christmas you actually just
ran up and yanked that guy
i stole that car and he walked for ups
i was like i'm bigger than you he worked
for
this is just the kid the one that my kid
had
anyways it was it was awesome it was
great traveler this is the first like
understanding
i had to get him away from the stockings
because like he
we woke up and all he was he got one
present the night before and he was like
he woke up and i was like i want my blue
fire truck i'm like
dude there's you should see what's going
on in here
because this is way cooler and he woke
up and he went to his
stocking and then there was like one
thing is like oh my gosh and he was just
so grateful
and i was like man this is the way that
we should be it's just be
so grateful for the little that we have
and then he have understood
that all the boxes in the other room
were for him
and that went away very quickly so
[Laughter]
idyllic communism to capitalism
like that you haven't you haven't
defended your assertion that santa is
for the parents though
i i i already agree though
because it's it's i
like i made a just just a call like pam
and earlier are we gonna do this do we
wanna
do you wanna like you know here's this
make-believe guy and
tell them whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
any parents listening to the show right
now in the car that would be an
excellent time
it's it's a weird existential thing you
go what are we gonna do like you have to
make a decision on that
about if you're gonna lie to your kid if
you're gonna lie to your kid
for the preservation of this christmas
spirit or if you're going to go you know
what we're going to be different parents
but then it's like well they go to
school i was like santa's not real i was
like then you're the [ __ ] kid that
like spoiled everybody it's like
it's a real thing so that has a premise
of the kid going to school i didn't
think that happened anymore
well i guess not an issue this year
technically yeah i was going to say
sure even still there's like charters or
there's like co-op schools or there's
home school i mean like
dude i don't know what we're going to do
i have no idea it's all dependent upon
traveler
i don't i grew up in a sister where it
was like this is how you learn
i'm like but that's not the way that i
feel like in bessler like [ __ ] you kid
you don't know
this is the way you learn as opposed to
if i had known there was a montessori
system
huh we had a whole episode about that
the episode you weren't on was entitled
i love the idea of the santa is actually
like a really useful thing to teach kids
that
parents and adults are not necessarily
to be believed i've always
that's my favorite justification i've
ever heard for it is it's really
cool no it's an important lesson right
for a kid that's funny i've never
thought
the vehicle but like but like the truths
of this world the kind of
the norms the expectations the stuff
adults tell you is how it has to be
at a very young age we teach every child
in the western world
don't necessarily believe what you've
been told i think that's i think that's
a really healthy
thing to have in society the only thing
that the only thing i pushed back on
that i was like pam and i we won't tell
traveler in a minute
or give me a second we because i
i want it to be important i want my word
to mean something so that he understands
that his word means something
so we go i need i want two minutes and
then as
right now it is 7 48 when the clock says
7
5 0 that's when it's he'll watch
and i go two minutes i was like dude you
got it and i better stop whatever it is
that i'm doing
because it's important it's not about
structure or anything it is about i want
him to understand that you don't lie
and when you say you're going to do
something or when you say something your
word better means something
so it becomes this thing was like do i
want to tell them about santa
that all went out the window when i was
like i'm going to do stockings
and i'm going to make rap presents that
are just from santa that pam doesn't
know about
that are just for me and i did like this
um
it's called a emblem ah man i can't
remember you get like this uh uh
embossing dust
and you take like this little torch and
you like heat it up and it becomes it's
like beautiful
full foil santa and so pam you know
about they woke up in the morning
there's
like stack of presents and i was like oh
what is it
she's like you did this i was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] or did this [ __ ]
i went hard i went full on santa
hey i thought i thought you were the
reason why i was
pressing you on it is because i thought
you were going to say with the jordans
as your setup like the beauty of santa
is if he doesn't like it you're like ah
well
santa i had i had to think about that i
was like but i also
guess you want good enough socks i was
like you can wear socks just like
daddy's like i do not like this one
[Music]
i remember my mom one year like i guess
when we found out that
santa wasn't real saying something like
it sucked because santa just got all the
credit all the time
that like i'd buy you something and my
family didn't have a lot of money when i
was a kid and they'd put a lot of like
effort into buying it and then
it would be from santa and i'd be like
whoa santa's amazing and she'd be like
for [ __ ] sake
you're just like parents it's like you
need to understand that you're not
always going to be the one
it's not about wow it's not about you
getting the credit
it's about a fashion show i was going to
say i love it i love that this is the
most worked up troy's ever been
yeah it was it was a thing it was
awesome but it took like
like christmas day was christmas day
like it was a whole thing
and then we went to travis and laura's
and he was like wait
it was like we were this jewish family
that gets like eight days of christmas
because it just kept going
ugh and it's so important for he and
ronan to like play together because they
understand it's like
i understand that's your toy but you're
gonna share right now and it's gonna be
okay
it's like all these lessons man i just
feel like i did
maybe i got him but i feel like a lot of
stuff that he's learning now
i am now learning as an adult so it's
just i don't know
the thing is yeah and people have to
relearn things from themselves too but
i don't know if i've said this on the
show before but i think one of the
coolest things that my parents did
that i always want to share in case
anyone is you know considering parenting
because i feel like it was so valuable
is if i would say stop or no uh when
being tickled or something they would
stop
100 a lot of parents don't do that
because they think it's funny because
your kids giggling or whatever but if i
said no
they would stop because the idea was
that my parents wanted to teach me that
i had the right to say no or stop to
something that i didn't like
is that not normal department usually
parents will continue
to tickle a kid or like play with them
if they're getting a
response rather than acknowledging the
word not and like
what happened was it wasn't like well
then you just don't have fun because i
guess what i did and i don't recall this
but my mom was saying
was if i didn't actually want to stop
being tickled i'd be like
okay go again and then i would ask to be
tickled again before saying no again so
i would just
end up learning that i could ask for
when i wanted it or when i didn't want
it and i just feel like it's a really
good lesson to teach two little girls
travel travel does it right now too it's
like well we'll stop you tickle tickle
tickles so i give them tickles and it
stops
[Laughter]
it's the same reason why if anybody
takes a look at my kid he's like he's
got this [ __ ] amazing long hair
and everyone was like oh it's a pretty
girl's like it's a dude and like what
are you gonna cut it i'm like who thinks
people think traveler is a girl oh dude
all the time
really she has beautiful hairs like he
does he's like
kick-ass hair like i wish i had that
hair um
people just naturally assume and i'm
like he's two
he's at home there's no reason for him
to have to cut his hair if he wants to
cut his hair then be like cool
but that's like an important thing every
kid like growing up is like you have
that picture of yourself just terrified
and screaming as they're cutting your
hair it's like
same thing alana like i want him to
understand like yo this is my body
and i'm going to make decisions for it
and i'm here to help guide those
decisions
but i'm not necessarily here to make
those decisions for him i'm here to guys
like hey are you hungry the white why
you're angry right now is because you
need to eat
so let's get some food yeah i respect it
um austin how was your christmas thank
you she will get into seoul
hopefully how was your christmas austin
i uh
i had a funny christmas story happen uh
over
over a couple day period so i i was um
on christmas eve i was finishing up some
stuff here and then i go home
early and then plan to take the day off
and i show up and angela's in the corner
working on a painting and she's like go
away and
she had done this sort of last second
idea for a painting
and so she shows it to me on christmas
morning and it's um
it's like this sort of van gogh eyes
um take on melee island from
from monkey island uh just kind of
spur the moment she knows i i love those
games the lucasarts
point-and-click ventures adventure in
general and i already have
my uh in the back corner over there uh
my grim fandango uh painting from her so
it's like gotta
go to the next one on the list i guess
and so it's really nice really just sort
of lovely surprise
and so um she's like i'm gonna
keep it here though you can take it to
the studio uh later i need to like
i want to photograph it and and then
she'll she takes like high quality
photos so she can make prints
so she puts it on her store to make
prints and then
one of the things that we do is that
around the corner from the studio is
like a
shipping store so whenever she sells
prints orders she usually gives them to
me and i take them in
and just drop them off to get mailed off
when i come in the studio who will wait
this has never occurred to me before if
you want i'm assuming this is a painting
on a canvas
if you want to have a print made you
take a picture
she photographs it and then like color
balances and very carefully
you know there's a whole art to
photographing paintings to making prints
it's it's very tedious
and i assumed some kind of yeah that's
what i was assuming some kind of
scanning process but i never really
thought of it i mean it's bigger cameras
are better now
yeah it's also bigger than so genuinely
like cameras have gotten
better than the scanning equipment in
terms of picture quality
yeah it's it's it's uh it's a challenge
uh but anyway so she she was like oh
you know it'd be cool to list this on
the store just kind of impulsively
so i come back the next day and there's
an envelope waiting for me on my spot
and i look at it and i was like is this
a a monkey island
like a melee island uh print
and she was like yeah how'd you know she
goes i didn't even tell you that i was
gonna
that i was gonna put that on my store
and i said because do you see
who bought it and she was like i have no
idea and i look and the
envelope is ron gilbert [ __ ]
and i was like it's awesome i was like
there's no chance in hell this is the
some other guy some other ron gilbert
who
instantly shows up and so she was like
yeah
he sent me an email and i go and i look
and he had he had he had somehow spotted
it
uh and then emailed her and been like
can i buy the the painting
she was like oh order has it it already
has an owner and i was like
does it uh i found myself with an
interesting dilemma of
uh do i sell my gift to uh
you can't do that obviously not no
obviously but it was really uh
it was really yeah it was really funny a
little 24-hour
like wow ron gilbert closely come to
selling it to him
how close did you come honestly i mean
it was non-zero non-zero percent
no i but she yeah she sent a print and
and i was like
i was like i i i was so charmed by the
fact that she didn't know who he was
uh and i was like you have any idea how
cool it is that
somehow this immediately made its way to
him and he
he jumped at the chance to buy one from
you immediately
i was like that's really cool how did he
find it though is my question
well my joke i was talking to a friend
and i was like
maybe every night he's searching like
uh melee island monkey island ron
gilbert uh on
twitter and uh yeah actually well
she i mean a lot of people reshared the
painting yeah um i saw it it's really
good but i also wanted to say um
angela made our logo which i got
yeah coffee coasters off oh no
i should get one um which means that she
is always linked in our bio so if you
want to check her stuff out it is always
in the description
on youtube because she's very talented
description is it yes it is indeed in
the description
for christmas austin i have been so
funny enough
i have been binging
media in general films and games uh
like crazy partly because i'm on the
dice jury and i and we got like
just an ungodly giants
there's so many [ __ ] games to get
through that i that i sort of
either didn't play or didn't even know
about
um so it's been one of these like it's
like going to the gym where i'm like
okay
every morning new game different game i
have to be very disciplined about it
because i can't possibly get through
them all if i'm not
and some of the games whenever you're
judging anything i'm not judging dice
but like where are you judging anything
some of the games are a bit more like
work than others right there's always
one or two in there
like the last it was part two it's it oh
my goodness me
wow it's been uh it's actually been it's
been a wonderful
mix of both where some are tedious and
then there's others that i'm like wow i
never heard of this
or i never or i didn't play it and i'm
really
glad that i finally did um and like it's
really
actually surprised me i'm liking this
more than i would have just guessed from
like the steam
thumbnail you know yeah yeah this is the
thing that you
learn in jury situations like that is
that a lot of indie devs are very bad at
marketing
yeah or they need it or they just don't
have the money
yeah i was going to say or just the
signal-to-noise ratio is just
it's just intrinsically hard to overcome
even if you have
all your ducks in a row and you're
amazing at marketing and
and you've got an amazing game it's
sometimes still just really freaking
hard to
i've been playing pathless and
it is really right dude you have not
mentioned that
i don't want to surprise you we're
creating content right now
i'm i'm i'm all i'm all a twitter pam
literally fell asleep right back there
last night because i was like here i
want you to put the headphones on
and she just watched me play and
listened
and it just it was so deeply meditative
and meditatively it is what
i not mechanically and everything else
obviously goes to sushima
is is is an incredible accomplishment on
a triple a level
but as far as like i just want to
explore this world
and the traversal the puzzle solving and
all of just the deeply meditative part
of it
the pathless is what it gave me what i
wanted from
ghost to sushima in in that regard and
dude i have to say
i'm your i'm your friend i think that's
your best
so so glad to finally confirm this
melodically musically whatever there's
so many of the of the uh
songs that do just kind of continue to
stick with me but it is just the
the use of it um
just everything it it is just i i
you and i've had the conversation before
as far as like snubs and i don't
necessarily
subscribe to the the notion of of
snubs because it just doesn't make any
sense like with awards
but i can definitely say yeah for the
awards but i can definitely say
unequivocally that this this game across
the board
uh from an art direction standpoint from
a mechanic standpoint from the
certainly from a score standpoint is
has worthy merits of of accolades
and accomplishments man so well done to
that team into you also that's very what
do
you think is your best work
i mean the cliche response to that is to
say
like that's like picking your your
favorite kid you know
like if you've and and so but it
i think that's that is a cliche because
it's an earnest response like
i don't think of any of my scores
as i don't think of them as ranked in
terms of better or worse outcome it's
more like what did i learn from them
and sometimes i learn a lot like they
drag me through the mud and they're
really hard and
and i i'm like i came out of it better
but it wasn't necessarily
like pleasurable in in execution there's
some that are like a breeze they just
flow and it's just
it just feels like wow that was cool but
then in hindsight i'm like
how easy and natural it was almost makes
me suspicious of if it could have been
any good because
i'm used to having to work hard for
things that feel like okay that turned
out all right
uh you know like journey being an
obvious example where where
that's one where that all seems to
correlate like that was really really
difficult um because i just was like
obsessed with leaving no stone unturned
and then it seemed to
turn out pretty well um but
so so i don't i don't know it's really
it's really hard
and the other thing is it's not just
difficult in some general sense it's
like
i kind of set a mission for myself on
each one like on erica it was
how tightly can i wrap around this
footage where it feels like
it feels as detailed as a movie score
would that has the luxury of
static unchanging footage but in this
case
it's not unchanging footage it's footage
that the player is actively engaging
with every few
seconds and and changing the the
emotions of and therefore
how nimble can i make a score truly and
that ended up being probably the most
technically complex score i've ever done
this one
rivals it but on this like glacier kind
of way i actually just
i'm just putting the final touches on
making a video for my youtube channel
about how the interactive systems in the
game work
because it's one of those where at any
given moment the system is asking
it the system is analyzing three pieces
of data from of the player
it's in the pathless yeah uh it's
wanting to know
where are you narratively meaning
and we and we analyze that based on how
many of the
bosses you've defeated but you can
explore in any order you want you know
it's
it's an open world and there's no mini
map or anything so it's just like
just have at it just just wander around
so that at any point we're saying
we use the bosses as like our way to
analyze
narrative progress there's a lot of
different things that we played around
with
trying to use and that ended up being
the one that made the most sense because
it's
it definitely feels like okay i've i've
done something substantive i've really
changed
and it changes the way the forest looks
and and it feels like it actually
impacts the world so it seems like okay
those are milestones
that we will hitch our star to
narratively so the music
has like this narrative structure where
the whole game re-skins musically after
you defeat a boss but you can beat
any one of them in any order so it's
like
it moves you to think of it like a
three-act play it moves you to act two
after defeating a boss any boss but then
there's also the
where am i on the island so the music is
combining that data with
certain things that are physically
specific to like
big chunks of the map so that if you
defeat this boss over here versus this
boss over there the music in and out of
that experience will be different even
though they both
the yeah it was it was took several
years of trying things
um there's also a real time component
which is as you
build up the kind of stamina bar from
shooting the arrows at the talismans you
can move
really fast and the music will speed up
and
get energized with you and slow down
without you so there's like
immediate feedback real time the music
will speed up if you just run really
fast but then there's also this like
where are you within the
you know 10 hour story as well going on
and it took a lot it took a lot so it's
one
you don't really notice it would take
multiple playthroughs of conscientiously
doing it very differently
to see these to see how it plays out
well
one thing that really helped me was we
did a listen to
or listen back of of the the score
and i didn't realize that you you had
actually
um created bespoke versions of those
songs like
this is not how you would hear them in
the world i was like i was trying to
wrap my head around that
because i think of like um gabriel's
oboe
like that that's a piece that you're
going to hear in this
[Music]
that's impressive you don't even have to
look annoys me every time
[Music]
oh so good it really is one of the best
melodies of all time
that's going to be a piece that you hear
in a certain part but
you were like that besides the intro and
the outro there's
all of these things are as i i think i'm
using this correctly procedurally
generated
so it's not procedural in that it's it's
it's it's more like um it's more like a
lego
lego box that has you know certain
combinations that can be assembled like
what mike is working on is actually
that's all
procedural generation is though well
it's
i guess for me learning don't don't yeah
no troy's
100 using it right here's here's the
distinction that i draw and you can
correct me
mike i think of procedural as like it's
down to the
to a far greater sort of
granular scale like to me
to me if if let's let's go let's zoom
out to the fullest of
i have a fully linear like i write a
song and i produce it like a record
and i've got that we'll call option a
and then i make a different song
and we'll call it option b to me it
doesn't feel like procedural generation
if i make a choice in the game and it
just toggles song a versus song b
but that is an interactive music system
in a very basic
rudimentary sort of way right but you
would not call that procedural
right i think at the point where this
the
the content of your music is being
adjusted based on gameplay variables so
things like it's speeding up or slowing
down
as you as you go up in speed via the the
shooting by the way i played it as well
i love it
um i need to i'm angry at your designer
for like the very first corridor i got
lost finding that annoyed me but other
than that it's brilliant
um the uh like that that would be
procedural because that's that's a
that's a moment where the interesting
procedural generation is people think of
procedural generation as like
all the humans leave the room and leave
the computer to make something
but it most of the time it is more that
the computer is
a book i just read about uh about it you
use the the metaphor of like
it's a stupid intern it's the computer
is a stupid intern who does the
boring jobs yeah we have this
conversation yellow
there you go it's all procedural there
you go so it's so that's
that's what this is like if you're if
you this i think i think austin you've
been doing procedural scores for years
like there's stuff in john wick hex that
you're doing that stuff with us well
obviously nowhere near the same extent
but like
i think i think that's been a part of
your process for a while even if you
wouldn't call it that
because i think in your head procedural
means literally like my prototype where
it's choosing which notes to play
but what's really interesting is with
that prototype
um i'm already at the stage where i'm
sick of that it sounds awful because
it's
because you're because it that magic of
that those first few notes being placed
down
um is taken away because it's it's not a
human it's computer guessing
so the next version of that prototype is
going to have like oh you can put in two
bars of austin playing music and then
it's going to riff
and iterate on that music and play with
it and explore it itself and do
you the kind of the thing that people
who are of moderate skill playing piano
will do where they'll just like start
playing something and they'll just kind
of
riff and do have fun with it right yeah
like not what you would call composition
but what would be kind of uh
to my ear would sound like music that's
the but that's my point is procedural is
very good when it's got good humans
guiding it and giving it rule sets so
now i'd say that all of your scores for
the last few years banner saga is
similar
if if if the version here you go here's
my definition
if if the version on the album is
different than the version you hear in
the game because the version you hear in
the game is affected by what you're
doing as a player by
definition it has to be procedural
because the computer has to be doing so
well
so troy is right oh
my god that's my ringtone
[Laughter]
i fair enough then in that case i think
i've never
not written a procedural score uh based
on because yeah
every slow which is one of the famously
reactive scores well that's
that's flow is the one that i always say
is the only one that i consider to be
i guess i just to me i i saw it like a
spectrum or a gradation where
once you reach a level of granularity
with the bits
of of construction material that's when
to me it starts to feel procedural
because it feels like the variability is
now so gigantic
that you couldn't reproduce it if you
tried like it's it that that's to me
but that's almost maybe a better term
would be like algorithmically generated
or something because that that yeah i
mean that's the one where lots of people
sorry to cut you off i think a lot of
people look at that end of this because
you're right it is a sprite a spectrum
right but like i think that end of the
spectrum is what a lot of people listen
to like stuff
like like my prototype which i've posted
on twitter from once again look at it
it's it's crap it's not like it doesn't
sound like music really it's fun
experiment it's called austin yeah
because
um but like but like that's that's the
one and i think a lot of people hear
that end of procedure generation go
well that's [ __ ] compared to an actual
composer and they lose interest
whereas i think yeah i think the the
best procedural systems that i've seen
and
and played with have been ones that are
you know
carrying the bags of the very very
skilled human involved basically like
the people who the
the programs they're doing the jobs to
kind of support
what what you're doing and i would say
that's what a lot of your scores do
yeah well fair enough and and i'm glad
to hear troy that
to that end it's um
it was a parent on a play through that
it's distinctly different from the album
uh that you know the and there's always
things on the album by the way i always
at some point
journey was the one that taught me this
just going back to your question a lot
of like what do i remember from each
project how do i think of them it's
always what did i learn
journey was the first time i ever
thought
going to make the album i am now
effectively starting from scratch
almost and i'm not i'm not going to
worry about
it being like an archive of your
experience of the game
in fact i can't stand because the way i
write the music for the game is also
very incompatible with just dumping it
into a playlist because sometimes
you know there might be 50 individual
pieces of music that
are one second long because they
they're meant to trigger over a very
specific thing or they're there to mask
a transition when such a new thing shows
up or a lot of
the endless this is the maternal issue
right where it was like why can't you
just put those tracks out i don't
understand but it doesn't actually work
that way and i
i know that i only just learned this
like last week um but i should have
known
that some of the way that music was
triggered in doom eternal was actually
based on the type of enemy that you were
fighting
so if you were fighting like a kakademon
maybe it wouldn't be as intense as it
gets if you're fighting
a baron or something like that like it
actually escalates based on the
difficulty of the enemies
that's actually not that uncommon in
terms of sorry troy just
to tap onto that really quick it's not
that uncommon i mean we did that on
syndicate and we didn't invent it for
that either where the
like the way the system worked in that
one was because it's a pet peeve of mine
in open world games where you can have
just
free form combat encounters at any point
when
the combat getting triggered by an
encounter that
you know the music has barely started
ramping up before it's you've already
killed everybody
um or or you you were like
you know i didn't mean to aggro that guy
and so you bail out immediately because
you're like doing a quest or whatever
and so
i i remember at the first meeting on
syndicate i said can i
can we design a system where it's
basically drawing a big circle like a
reasonable radius of
of potential aggro aggroable enemies
and say let's basically add up the
damage potential or the threat potential
of everybody within this circle around
the enemy and so if it's a million low
level guys or it's one
super high level guy or some combo in
between blah blah blah
you end up with the system generating a
number and if if the
and then we draw a line based on your
own
damage potential like how good is my
gear what level am i blah blah blah and
if that number between those if they're
basically sufficiently close to one
another
and and the threat is not that much of a
threat
then the music can't be triggered uh and
so you know quick encounters especially
assassinations and stealth kills they
will never trigger the music
and uh and if you get into a fight and
you intentionally prolong it but it's
like one low-level guy that also won't
trigger so in order to prevent the
fatigue of just like constant encounters
ramping up the music so we were doing
the same thing fundamentally of just
how big of a situation am i in and
is it worth hearing music for and then
there's other variables beyond that but
that was kind of the starting
position and i i'm always so grateful
when when games do that i i one of the
things i wanted to talk about
i don't want to derail because troy you
were about to say something um
but i've i've spent many hours now with
final fantasy vii remake
in order to to um to
expand on my earlier positions about the
game i
i have a far more interesting you've
changed your mind you think it's you
think it's excellent now i've added
nuance to my opinion
uh but but troy what were you about were
you about to say something
i was just gonna say it's if normally
you know this like i did not want to
listen to hamilton before i went to go
see the music i wanted
for that to hit me fresh and what i
understand
what this is a great example of is that
in the same way that you cannot it's not
apples to apples to call a movie a game
and a game a movie
they're totally separate kinds of
experiences just because you're viewing
them on a screen that is the portal by
which it is delivered to you does not in
any way
make it indicative of the same type of
entertainment in the same way to say
that austin writes songs
is such not even reductive it it's a
non-sequitur it doesn't make any sense
at all
which is one reason why composition
film scores as an um
awards category doesn't really make
sense because no other
form of media or entertainment tv film
plays anything else alike
a composer even john williams when you
you famously tell the story
where he's a stephen you know i missed
on on bar 182 i missed the whole thing
but but that was the
the musician's best take is like then
we'll re-edit the film
that is about the limit of a influence
that a composer is going to have
on the filmmaking of a game i was even
watching
not always true but bro but sorry of a
movie
you know what i mean no but no but in
general that that there are exceptions
to that there are
if christopher nolan famously likes to
get music before they even start
shooting he likes
music but he likes music more than
dialogue i think christmas
that's probably sometimes just balances
it out so you can't hear the dialogue
oh my goodness i think that they can't
influence it but it's not you going hey
i'm actually going to help
influence that i'm influencing design
i'm influencing mechanics i'm
influencing the fundamental way that
this game works
that's very different that's not just
like oh you wrote this song
that's a totally different thing and and
what i was going to say to people is i
would really really suggest
um listening to this score
as a piece first and then playing the
game
because you'd be like oh my god that's
that small piece here
that happens here after you free cernos
or whatever it's it's it's just like
it's been a really really cool
subconscious thing of
of how uh i really want to reach out to
the team just and how many people are
are there 15 um it's more than that but
not much about 20 i think
you know there was a few contractors
like the writer and a few other folks
that came in you know a couple extra
animators and things and there's the
core
as a side note one of my favorite little
details is
the the number of musicians on that
score just kept going and going and
going the final total is 104. so i love
that it's like five times more
musicians than the developer and um
and that's not uncommon if you record
something orchestral that the orchestra
just scales and numbers a lot faster
than developers typically uh so it's not
the first time it's happened but it's
probably the widest margin i've ever had
but a few of the part of it was that any
opportunity to just add more musicians
at some point i was like well the
number's so out of control i'm just
going to see how far i can push this
there's a few areas of the game where
like
a couple of the folks from giant squid
reached out to me midway through and
they're like
hey by the way you know i'm a
percussionist and i've got a few things
lying around at home if you want and so
there's a few places where
when you're in a given part the designer
of that part
is also part of the score you're hearing
in that spot
uh which i never did that before and and
that i was like that that
feels good i like that i want to i want
to look for
opportunities like that again in the
future um cameo like a musical cameo
that's lovely
yeah exactly can we get your uh updated
take on the final fantasy 7 remake oh
[ __ ] you're going to harp on that go for
it he loves it
and then we can go to seoul because i
feel like it's very musical episode it
all makes sense
it's yeah it's true and i don't know
also presumably that was the title of
this episode so people have waited
on the intro as well 40 minutes
well so i i had i had i had
played um the remake very little
um and then what i had done is i had
listened to a fair bit of the music on
its own
kind of like honestly what troy is
talking about and i i played the hell
out of the original 20 years ago
um but um i hadn't touched the new one
and um so
a lot of what i had heard as we talked
about before were where
um fake like synth orchestra
and i just kept thinking why
why would they do that when they've
clearly gone to such extreme lengths
in every other department and
so then i finally was like and then and
then when i said that
when we were talking about the game
awards and i'm looking at the comments
there's a lot of people that are like
he's full of [ __ ] it was the best score
and so i was like all right well let's
see so i
installed the game and um
my my i have some i have some
disconnects with the game in general but
but specifically musically it's
interesting because the first
bunch of cues were all live orchestra
and so i was playing through and i was
like what the hell was i listening to
before
and so i reached out to a friend who
knows more than me about it and i was
like
what is my disconnect here what is my
confusion
and she was like well you know the thing
is there's like seven and a half hours
of music and so they basically just said
okay this skew this cue this people do
those live
and these vast swaths of others we know
so it's very uneven
so half hours something like that i mean
they released a soundtrack album that's
like seven
cds that's ridiculous seven and a half
hours
that's not that uncommon here's the
difference so ea um star wars
uh fallen order that was a seven
seven ish seven and a half hour score
all of which was recorded
london symphony at abbey road so they
spent way more money on the score for
fallen order than final fantasy vii
and this is a game that is an expensive
way to record an orchestra as well
that's not
just yeah yeah they're most expensive i
was to say i don't i literally don't
think there is a cheat like a more
expensive option that's not just
about like even more musicians
sort of because but that's not like they
would smoke
yeah exactly yeah um
um um so i
i i was i found myself thinking you know
um
um that was a
disappointing it's it's probably just
pragmatic at some point they're like we
don't have infinite budget we're
spending an unbelievable amount on
cinematics and whatnot but i was like
okay
in their defense some of these cues like
the very opening
big super cinematic cutscene which is
you know giving you these coral riffs on
the one winged angel you know surfer
roth
uh like they're clearly playing with
their
audience saying we know what you're
expecting and so i was like okay
that's cool i'll give them that that
sounds really nice
um but where they lose me uh well
actually two
two more points i stand by the idea that
it is still overwhelmingly derivative of
the original and for me that
if you're you're basically just
retroactively awarding naboo umatsu
in 1997 by giving it an award in 2020.
yes the music is not technically
a literal recreation they they hired
several very talented composers
um and in the case of one of them in
particular musashi homazu
he did kind of do his own thing more
he definitely was free to kind of just
add to the canon
but overwhelmingly it's there to remind
you you know you're sitting there
playing and it's doing the like you know
or what is it oh
you know the famous little battle piece
oh my god we've we've seen the wizard of
oz we see the man behind the curtain
there i'm a fallible guy
oh my goodness god bleeds but you know i
just no i'd lie you more now i think
that's what it is
yeah it it leans it leans very very
heavily
on the familiar material uh and so
that's why i'm like
i just don't see how you can award a
score
this way i stand all the more redoubled
in because not just that
but it beats it to death so
as soon as you're able to start running
around the slums and taking on little
missions to like spread your reputation
as a merc and tifa's telling you you
know we got to get your
you know your the word out on who cloud
is it just
loops clouds theme endlessly through
that and and the thing that from an
implementation standpoint i was like
this is a disaster
because first off the music is bloody
loud like it is just
bulldozing the dialogue at all times
there's one part in the game where i
turned the music off because the song
was looping and it was annoying me so
much
it's really really frustrating and
especially because they also don't do
any dynamic mixing as far
at least it didn't feel it to me of and
i don't mean to be reductive of what was
clearly a herculean effort on behalf of
a [ __ ] ton of people like it's
it is an achievement of a game in so
many regards but looking through this
prism of audio and music
you know as you run around there's all
these npcs talking
and their voices are just as loud as
tifa who's what who's
showing you around taking you to the
next place so i was like if i didn't
have subtitles on
i would have no [ __ ] clue what's
going on because it is just a chaos of
voices and on top of that the score at
full power
blaring away on cloud's theme you know
the what was the overworld theme in the
original
and i hear that and it's very lovely
that one was being performed by the
tokyo philharmonic properly very nice
sounding
but it also had nothing to do with what
was going on screen it was like i
accidentally left itunes running or
spotify running
and and like i can't figure out how to
turn it off and i kept saying
that for me implementation is more than
fifty percent of what makes
for a great game score you know that's
where it how it
how it creates full stop right across
the board every single aspect of a game
right is that final implementation is
what makes it
yeah exactly like you can have the most
amazing mechanics and if they're poorly
tuned
then then you're it doesn't matter you
know like that's why
you look at a game like ori and uh the
mechanics are so
beautifully tuned that it's never
frustrating even even at its
most challenging because they just they
really really
zeroed in on like these perfect balances
of skill
and how far they want to let you go bef
you know before they kind of give you
updated checkpoints and things like that
so this just seemed so
savvy to what the player's lived
experience will be and perfect example
gareth the composer of those scores a
friend of mine an
excellent composer he um one of the
conceits that he made of the ori scores
was
we will have for the most part no
percussion in the music because
there's such rapid-fire sound effects of
every interaction or he has he's like
let's
let that serve as the percussion so the
music is doing
this lyrical melodic stuff and letting
all the little fine grain
fast transients fill in in between well
they're
ready for that yeah exactly they seem to
have no kinds of considerations like
that in final fantasy vii so it's like
it's better in many ways than i
initially gave it credit for but in no
way do i think it should even be
eligible for these awards
i i like the hot topic i like this from
you that was
interesting i used to like always think
like when you recorded there was this
uh mutt laying was was always a big
proponent of
or phil spector too of like stacking
things so you stack vocals you stack
guitars
and i remember working with the producer
i was like all right so we're gonna
stack he goes no why would you do that i
was like
because i wanted to be big he goes if
you want it to be big then you make it
be the only one
and it's not about filling space it's
about carving it
and that's why finding a game that is
able to go
man there's some really ambitious things
that we want to do
but instead of doing these 20 things
let's do
five of them and let's do it really well
he goes that's how you get a big sound
is you have
one guitar and you balance it because
otherwise you just get there's only a
certain amount of bandwidth for
frequencies
and those sounds just start competing
and that's why i learned
from you austin you don't have a bit any
orchestra that has a big piano
a piano takes up so much just frequency
bandwidth
that's why you want to have like we were
talking about reporting and
i would have these ideas i was like i
wanna have this big grand piano and this
this um wayne miller the producer was
like absolutely not
he was like is it the only instrument
because if it's the only instrument
we'll do a grand piano he goes but if
you want piano on this it's going to be
an
upright because it just takes up less
space and you can actually have more
impact so you hear the piano i was like
man
dude yeah it's weird how pianos pianos
make orchestra sound smaller
not bigger it's one of the only
instruments that actually seem to trick
your ear into thinking there's less
happening and there's less
um sonic mass to it uh same amount of
keys
same amount of keys just less frequency
man
i also think part of it it's like a
familiarity thing
is that that's just because we we all
went to school with like a piano in the
assembly hall is that what it was that's
actually the piano or something that you
know yeah really okay yeah i was gonna
say i was just starting to say i think
also partly it's psychological because
it's very grounded and familiar
and and so it makes it emblematic of a
thing right yeah yeah
violence doesn't make you go a huge lush
orchestra but you see a big piano and
it's like that's a piece of furniture
that was always my that was always my
hypothesis about why john williams
doesn't use piano in star wars because
it would have humanized the score and
made it feel familiar ding ding ding
ding ding ding
ding ding ding yeah actually so funny
enough
funny enough they're actually there
actually is
piano in uh it's it's very rare in
general but in the battle of hoth
he does use piano as a percussion
instrument and then lucas
cut it out of the cut it out of the
movie and so if you listen to the album
when they're when the rebel troops are
preparing for the arrival of the walkers
the atats
um is he reaching for the i knew it yes
right well then in that case
i'll commit fully so the rebel the rebel
soldiers are all in the little trenches
and they're just looking down
and and you hear the like jurassic park
footsteps right of the approaching atats
and they look am i weird that i say yeah
you are
no it's out that's it it's not the 80s
please stop both of you
to pull a mic on this so so john
williams wrote this figure
it's just piano which is very i'm all
tangled in my headphones here
it's just piano going it's all it and
and then you know timpani adding in
these little so it's like
um and dope oh no that's not that's in
the movie
if you go if you listen to the battle of
hoth on the soundtrack it starts with
after the initial intro stuff you hear
that and that's
the shot of the walkers approaching and
when you watch the movie it's just
silence there's no so george lucas was
the stupid intern on that one
there's a procedurally generated score
by the criteria we've already
established
lucas uh lucas uh chopped up and moved
around williams music
quite a lot in those movies and there's
there's all manner of instances return
of the jedi huge chunks of that is music
from the first film
attack of the clones has huge amounts of
music in it from phantom menace where
john williams wrote something
and then in the edit bay they just they
just changed it um
i would be lying if i said i hadn't done
the exact same thing to people
it's it's actually pretty normal uh i
won't judge too heavily
i'm literally a dj so sort of something
i do pretty often
yeah yeah all right well as a dj what is
your thought on
soul but specifically as a dj something
better by the way i just want that i was
like i went to piano
that's true it's very very musical uh
it has i like it uh soul did not do very
much for me
to the extent where i i'm reading my
twitter feed going
is there something wrong with me it does
my brain not work um
because i felt like part obviously full
spoilers
um part of the message of the movie was
did you both see it
i've seen it yeah okay so you have a man
chases his dreams and then get his big
break and then die
um and then if if the message was
supposed to be
you know enjoy the little things why
can't you also
uh chase your dreams and enjoy the
little things at the same time and then
i felt like the message was going to be
something about like well actually what
he loves is teaching but it never
doubled down on that
in any way um to the extent where it
just kind of left me in a way that i was
like
i don't know what what i'm supposed to
take from this
and i was wondering is that a thing
that's because i am someone who's been
able to chase my dreams very efficiently
um and that i do also take the time to
smell the roses like is that why it
didn't appeal to me
um but i also felt like there was some
some parts of it that i just found
really strange that i know this is a
sensitive topic but
having a black protagonist you know be
removed from his body
put in a cat and then voiced by a white
woman who kind of solved some of his
problems was just a very
weird thing to me and when when i it's
like get out but fun
it's just just art um it's that weird
it's that weird taking over the body of
a black guy it's like a really very
strange
hacks well but it's it's kind of it's it
feels like one of those things where did
no one in the room realize what they
were
doing so they pulled a black writer on
pretty late into production and i know
that there's a quote from him saying
because when i when i had seen it i was
like i don't know if i'm just like
getting the wrong read or like i'm like
you know i'm not black am i weird for
feeling that this is uncomfortable but
then i did go and read a bunch of things
that black writers had said about it and
generally
that was the consensus was no this was
pretty strange
um the particular note of the the
barbershop scene
where basically tina fey solves his
problems
in actually bonding with the people
around him in a way he couldn't is like
why would you give she's better in that
space than he is
right and he's a black man in a very
like iconically supposedly that i could
i should link the article that i was
reading um
like black space around other black men
uh and she's the one to bond with them
uh that that was something that was
noted in consistently across things that
i read was being really odd
for the record i i i read
because well i got a lot to say and i
don't want to i don't want to jump i've
been
i've been dominating too much of the
time here uh but
i felt like it was very clear to me
and i actually have generally the same
response to the film
i was really underwhelmed especially
given the bar of pete doctor's previous
work
um i was like i really wanted to love it
and i didn't i have a whole host of
reasons why they
that haven't come up yet but in that
particular
one i did read an article um
um uh from somebody that was saying
pretty much exactly what you just said
but i remember at the time thinking the
same article it wasn't
maybe yeah it wasn't like i saw a friend
share a twitter thread where somebody
had aggregated a lot of
black uh film critics
response to the film and it ran the
spectrum from
glowing praise to to like vehement
hatred
and i um i was reading one of the more
negative ones where they brought this up
and it it to me in the film and again
this i i know that i know the counter
reply to this already
uh but it's still nonetheless read to me
as it was not about
the racial dynamic remotely of her
character it was just simply the
uh his his his his sort of thoughtless
pursuit
of his dreams had made his it made him
oblivious to other human beings and
that's she's not even she's not even a
white character like we don't know what
race she is i like i get all that
she's pretending to be white to annoy
people right that's like isn't there
like a throwaway line of like i said
because the most annoying tina fey's
voice yeah middle-aged white woman is
the most annoying voice or something
it's not like i found this i
wasn't offended it was just like choices
that i was like these feel
odd um in a way that i just found very
strange but the
the main one to me like i thought a lot
of the music was beautiful i thought it
was like
shocking realism in some parts like the
way that the city looked it was
absolutely amazing
um i loved a lot of the voice cast uh
people i'm familiar with and already a
big fan of but
for the most part i just left it being
like i don't know what you're trying to
tell me
um and i feel like it got convoluted by
the way that they tried to tell the
story
uh just yeah just under underwhelmed
overall
um mike how did you how did you like it
i feel like i saw you tweet about it
i liked it no yeah i i saw i i'm deaf
i'm in pixar definitely i think the
tweet i said was like pixar know how to
make me cry or whatever like i i
i react exactly as p like if if
if pixar have like a a chart on their
wall of how they won't be able to be
like
knocked around by their emotional
aspects of their plots then i'm the
the poster child for that because i'm
100 on board with their films just in
general i'm a sucker for it i'm i'm
you know i'm into it i definitely yeah i
definitely as i was watching it had the
same kind of like
i'm i remember as i was watching i am
really looking forward to reading five
articles
about this by people who understand this
a bit more i
the the message of it the kind of that
that did connect more with me i think
because
i definitely am so you know very driven
career person
um who also does and he does struggle to
like
step back from it like i've definitely
never i've not not always got that work
life balance right so a lot of that kind
of did speak to me because
i never have quite figured all of that
out so i definitely connected on that
level
but yeah it did feel like a film it felt
like a film it felt like a film though
it felt like a film which had poor
machine
like it felt it felt like a film that
was one film
and then maybe aspects of the main
character were changed
and then they didn't necessarily think
about what how that recontextualized the
story i think i read somewhere that was
originally about an animator
like it was originally about an
obsessive animator
who died and that kind of made more
sense that explains
you know why the afterlife is rendered
as the history of animation and why all
of this stuff is
is doing different things and an
animation is a very isolating
private profession my my partner works
in animation
i work in games which is similar in a
lot of ways these are jobs where you
kind of
you do well by being kind of often kind
of siloed off
whereas it strikes me as being a jazz
musician would be a very fulfilling
lots of people lots of interaction being
a teacher would also be lots of
interaction lots of
public space i it feels like something
where
that element of the story was changed
and then that a lot of the problems i
have with the consistency seem to stem
from that change but that's
my instinct is always trying to figure
out why something i don't like isn't
perfect
uh but that felt like that felt like a
explanation but it definitely worked for
me emotionally like i i teared up and
i was hip with every beat and i laughed
a lot as well like it was it was funny
i did laughter i liked horses there yeah
the the
lincoln and and which was what's the bad
american president jackson
edward jackson lincoln and jackson hate
yeah yeah that joke
that was that was pretty good yeah it
did
there was there's lots of there was lots
of good stuff in there but yeah
definitely it felt at war with itself a
little bit i guess
yeah i just keep wondering if it if it's
just not for me like i'm also someone
who gets very stuck in work all the time
but i'm also very happy so i'm like you
telling me that i shouldn't be doing
this but then at the same time i'm still
the kind of person who you know it was
snowing on
uh christmas eve so i just went and sat
out in the snow for 30 minutes didn't
take my phone and just sat there and
smiled drinking my tea watching the snow
so it's like
i just don't know what you're trying to
tell me with this like should i
don't follow my dreams um or like
like try not to follow my dreams too
much like where i don't know i just felt
like this is something maybe i just
don't relate to because my twitter feed
is full of people being like
don't take life for granted i'm like i
don't think i do so
maybe it's just not for me do you think
it's maybe an age thing not to be
patronizing but do you think it
like for me it feels like a very
middle-aged film in that respect that
like
maybe kind of taking account of your
life i assume you're not maybe
at the stage yet where you've had the
whole like all the
not midlife crisis but the kind of
thinking about everything and i mean
possibly but
i feel like that would be odd
considering it's a pixar movie for all
ages
um they should try to be relatable to
everyone right no but but the
incredibles is explicitly a midlife
crisis movie so see but
i get the
so yeah fair enough yeah yeah
maybe that's it maybe they did a bad job
of conveying why this mattered to the
protagonist and maybe
no i just keep feeling like it's a
problem with me but it could be like i
felt like i really cared about joe and i
wish i could have cared about joe
more and i i wanted to see his ark and i
wanted to see where he was going a lot
more than i cared about 22.
um and i feel like some of those
beautiful moments i would have wanted to
happen for him
and i think maybe that was part of but i
don't know i again i'm i'm like on this
one i think it's my problem uh something
wrong with me
but well i i i i i'm with you and i
think it's i think it's about the script
i don't think it's i don't think it's
you missing it i think that i think
i think they um i think there were
um it felt almost like
this is so easy to just arm chair uh
you know monday morning quarterback kind
of [ __ ] but like
i it felt like an unfinished
draft where they had all these great
ingredients and they didn't quite figure
out how to connect them
and they just finished the film preempt
you know
sort of prematurely to me troy i'm dying
to know you're you're yeah
you've been very quiet you keep you keep
threatening
i know exactly yeah
i think it was a very clever movie
and i on a daily basis
sit in my library i get my morning cup
of coffee
and i open up whatever book
i'm trying to suss out the very
questions or answers that the movie
posits so like this is my conversation
is my jam like this is the [ __ ] that i'm
into right now
what is the afterlife what is the
purpose of life
what is life what is my purpose who am i
all of that
so this movie pam walked away she was
like man do you ever think about like
that stuff was like
yeah like constantly daily like i
as a 20 year old thinks about sex i now
think about existentialism and all that
[ __ ]
i think mike or you kind of hit on
something there i think it's possible
for you alana that joe gardner is not
late 20s it's a man in his 40s
when it first starts out possibly i mean
early 40s for sure when it starts off i
was like oh
they're basically doing mr holland's
opus but i can't about joe it was my
point
it's what they did after joe there's a
difference between
caring and going what am i supposed to
be doing is i'm not supposed to be
chasing my
dreams you right now you're chasing your
dreams
the difference between that position
joe's is he has chased them
and it has thus far eluded him
and my favorite scene if i can have one
of those
is standing out and you
get to the show you get to do the thing
and he has his big moment he was like if
you don't let me play tonight it'll be
the biggest mistake of your career
he stands up he has this powerful moment
and it pays off and he goes
and they do the quick cut of all the
songs and his mom is in the front row
she's like that's my son
he gets everything and he's standing
outside
i just thought it would feel different
that's a
powerful moment to display regardless of
age
because the people that are looking back
and going i never got my
shot can go maybe that wasn't what i was
going for all along
it's mr holland's opus we are your
symphony
your life is what it is and it's neither
good nor bad it's neither
made it or missed it is your life is
your story
you did this and for him to finally
realize was like
the thing that i've been avoiding death
which is really not
i don't know the great beyond is is just
the giving up
of this life the giving up of his dreams
the giving up of what he thought was his
purpose
and going i i don't exist to teach
i don't exist to play piano what i exist
is to let this person feel okay with the
world
and that's it are there things that they
could have done better
sure it never even dawned on me
the race thing never at all it was
simply
here's what happens when you shut up and
listen and that is not
a race thing that's a person thing
so it never hit me that way at all
i think there's a lot of things he could
have done differently with the movie
tina fey is
pizza she's always great but
her performance is unremarkable jamie
foxx
holy crap you prove again you're truly a
great actor
he really is a solid actor
he executed that role perfectly the cat
thing was
funny pixar has come a long way since
being a cowboy
and an astronaut like holy [ __ ] i didn't
cry
it didn't another midlife crisis movie
by the way sorry i just realized toy
story is 100 in my life
absolutely growing up forgetting about
who you are as a kid playing with stuff
but man it's just being worried about
the younger man like
there are things in there that i i can
understand but
like if it's if if the point is
something to do with like don't get so
focused on what you want to accomplish
that you don't enjoy life
i just feel like they could have hit
that theme harder why did you have me
see
you know that this field with the boat
where they're trying to get people out
of their hole like it was a cute
throw away for the guy who works in the
stock market but like how did that sell
that point is by the way
if i may i just want to wrap it up by
saying this
a friend of mine was at the one-on-one
cafe i'm walking out he looks over and
he sees
a tall slender man in a wool fedora
getting into
a beat-up nissan pathfinder and he stops
him and he was like i'm so sorry
to bother you but i just i think you're
brilliant i'm i'm a huge fan of your
work
and i would just really love to buy you
a cup of coffee
and so he said that he takes a minute
and he talks with him
and he says of all the years of of your
writing
both poetry and songs what is the piece
of advice that you could give to me a
songwriter and a writer
and he says write down everything and
save it because there are songs that you
are currently writing that your future
self will explain to you
and you may not even understand it but
your future self will
and that was leonard cohen that was my
guess
so maybe you don't who's the other one
in the story
my friend brian foster
my friend brian foster so
the point of that is that maybe you
don't get it maybe it doesn't hit you
but maybe when you're 45
and you look back and you go [ __ ]
maybe it will so it's not about the
movie failing or succeeding
maybe it's that wherever you are in your
life
your future self needs to explain it to
you i think that's it's
not about being wrong when you're
younger either it's also about like
right like it's like going back to any
like if you if you ever go back to any
movie you watch as like a kid and watch
it
like now as an adult like you see five
layers that weren't there before it
doesn't mean
the kid was stupid just means the kid in
your 20s you are like you're trying to
go for every goal you can you're getting
yourself set up and yes you're
absolutely right like you have the best
work-life balance in the world you can
be doing everything
but there is definitely something that
switch that flips like when you hit
middle age basically i forget that but i
also
and i also don't want to be the person
in their 20s who's like shut up old
dudes what are you
i know what i'm talking about get out of
here but one day
it just seems a bit a bit um reductive
to be like
not getting it because because your age
like i feel like there have been movies
about
people wait like you know the irishman i
wasn't like i don't get it
even though i couldn't possibly relate
to the situations in that film
i still felt um i i still do think it's
an issue with me probably but i felt
like the issue was more with the fact
that i am someone who has chased my
dreams and i do
feel like i think it's confusing
communicating
yeah i think it's a bad communication
anyway like i think it does
i think it's flawed in like having a
consistent perspective i think that's
true i think a lot of the stuff that i
think me and troy are talking about and
connecting with
we're kind of putting that on the movie
to an extent i think someone's just
gonna say does go on
i was gonna say i think you're
projecting what you needed from it
um which that's we all do that like
sometimes you see it you see a thing
like i watched immediately after this i
realized you know pixar put out another
film this year i didn't see which was
onward
which i had not seen and that blew me
away i
i loved it a hundred fold more um and
that's also a film
about a young guy trying to have a last
experience with his father which is
something i could
deeply connect with so it's like i'm
bringing something to that
uh to that film that that they you can't
bank on
with every audience member so i think i
think there's a lot of that for me the
just the one thing i want to
add was that maybe it's just purely from
a
like a writing standpoint but i they
off handily mention an idea in the film
that they didn't play with that i
thought was one of the most compelling
ideas
i'd ever seen in a pixar film maybe any
film which is where they're on their
ship of the realm of lost souls
and they're like some of the people in
here are lost souls and some of the
people are
in the zone and they're in the flow and
that the border between those is
actually
kind of razor thin razor thin and
permeable and i was like holy [ __ ] what
an idea
that that that magic moment where you
feel like you're on fire and all
the cylinders are going could be one
hair's breath away from someone who is
just going through the motions in life
and a zombie who's disconnected and
catatonic to everything i was like
what a concept a whole movie should be
about that
right and then there's a little truth to
that for the win by the way
granddaughter was my favorite do you
guys know who graham norton is because i
was watching that film and i was like
yeah there's no way americans know
graham norton it's great and autumn like
a thing in america now fair play good
for him it may be like a tea kettle
thing for me
or or something i 100
i love graham norton yeah i do oh i love
him as well but i always thought of him
as like a british celebrity 100
yeah endemic to the empire for sure but
i i had no idea that's who that was i
was like
who is moon dust or whatever his name
was he was really good
yeah i mean there are a lot of things
about it that i really liked i just had
trouble with
the with the message and i think that
that's part of what i was trying to
mention there austin is
you gave me all these little bits of
different things some of which i found
really interesting and some of which i
was like why are you telling me this
when
i feel like i should be on this path
about joe
that that i'm now getting this side
thing that just kept happening all the
time so totally agree
like the student coming to the door the
young girl who plays trombone
like but but that was not again right it
was such an unearned moment where
where she's like i should quit and then
22 on behalf of joe says yeah you should
like screw it life screw everything
and then the kid just seemingly
inexplicably goes well let me play for
you first
and so it's like you really have to
psychoanalyze of like the kid didn't
want to quit she just wanted to
have a little pushback in that and i did
actually go back and rewatch that scene
where it was i missed it the first time
is when
when 22 joe takes the trombone away
you see her have a look on her face of
of the
how uncomfortable she feels with it not
in her hands and so she takes it back
and play but i was like
it was like okay so we did the teaching
bit now let's move on to the career bit
like it just it felt like
you we could zero in on any one of the
whole movie could be about him coming to
terms with being a teacher
and that not recognizing a failure to
achieve his dreams you could make a
whole move of that or
that's what i think i wanted or the flip
or this
or the or the idea of i'm willing to
chase this dream and and the teaching
thing is is
i i don't want to you know it's not fair
to resent these kids uh they deserve a
teacher who cares about teaching
although he does care about teaching
because of the opening scene where that
girl
uh uh gets all into the moment and he's
like wait let's stop and celebrate
something magical that happened here
i agree it it's like there were so many
good ingredients and they
it was like i'm cooking i think it's
also possible
that there's a version of the script
where he just goes to the great beyond
or he becomes a mentor
and people are like uh we don't want to
give the message a way that in order to
achieve your dreams you have to die
so i i think that there's probably
because him walking out the door is like
well that doesn't make any sense it's
like i'm going to live my life
it's like uh so i can look at this and
go
i i think that the movie was having to
serve many masters it's like let's keep
it for kids
but it's not it's not a kid-friendly
script it is
it is absolute like you said it up
neither was up
and by the way i feel like this is a
much better movie than up
to me up to me is an amazing opening few
minutes and then a
pretty good subsequent film no no it is
it is a
great short that they tacked on another
story that i couldn't tell you anything
about except the squirrel
that's it i think there's a dog that's
cute too the dog no that's the same dog
but he goes squirrel
that's all i remember yes yes same but
which ironically they're now trying
to share this it feels like a much
better movie than
than uh but it definitely feels like the
spiritual successor to that movie
well the same director you know pete
doctor directed that and he also
directed monsters inc
um and like to me he did another midlife
crisis movie
yeah they're all mid-life crisis movies
doctor is
truly extraordinary as a filmmaker and
this felt like it was it just felt
it was kind of a little all over the
place that's exactly how my favorite
comedic moments in a pixar movie ever
it's when they turn he's like can
anybody tell me what he did wrong and
there's the one monster sitting there
with one big eye
he's got a notepad he goes and when he
coughs his eye gets bigger
and it gets me every go backwards
is [ __ ] amazing to me until until
ratatouille came out
monsters inc was the the unchallenged
champion of all pixar films for me
that's great
i thought i thought that sol was
definitely funny i thought it was
beautiful like
genuinely shockingly beautiful but i was
like oh my god oh god
and the the 2d 3d hybrid stuff was
really cool like really really cool
yeah there are a lot of things that i
really liked and i definitely you know
this isn't one of those things where i
think anyone who
did get something out of it like that i
can't understand
that it's just from for me personally i
was just like i
i think the issue i had was with like i
feel like you've already touched on the
sustain with it it trying to do too many
things where i feel like it had a
stronger
through line than i would have felt more
i just
wanted you to give me joe's arc give me
his journey and i don't feel like i
got that from it i feel like i wanted
the well i should be a teacher because
actually i love this it's the
i'm chasing something that i don't even
really care about or something like that
you know we didn't even really found out
what he ended up doing in the end
really um we don't know i didn't like
him
yeah for the record i did like the fact
that his final answer to the question of
what are you gonna do is i don't know
uh that to me was like that's a that's a
that's a mature
take like you're you don't have to know
uh that was a saving grace for me
uh it just felt like i didn't quite earn
that payoff but as a payoff that's a
good payoff
you know yeah because we're very used to
hero journeys like we're very used to
being told like
no they're going to want one thing
they're going to realize that's not the
right thing and they're going to need
another thing and they're going to do
that like
actually having a character go is
actually kind of that's that's bold
that's why that's why i like i agree
that there are issues with how it was
done but i think that's a really
interesting
did you see did you guys see onward
no oh because that that film to me as
to the point i won't say anything else
because it's so crucial to not spoil
anything but to the point you just made
mike that was why i was like
oh my god this movie was so mature
but um but so so highly recommended but
but as a final comment
on seoul just since we're on the subject
so much of music in
in this one i will they do get a lot of
points for
john baptiste you know who's the
bandleader on colbert
um was they they mocapped his hands for
every time
it's joe playing piano and it's very
very
authentic like they're the
representation of jazz and all the
performances
john baptiste was a big part of all that
and and he did all the
performing and arranging and then who
would have ever when they announced that
come on yeah when they announced that
those guys were doing a pixar film i was
like
what pixar film is that gonna be because
all that wait until you
hear the score for mank i have i have
heard it
dude it's yeah it's another it's funny
how the two most
jazzy uh scores of the season uh both
involve them and are both
couldn't be further from the nine-inch
nail although this is way noser
this is just nine inch nails in a major
key uh is
what it boils down to um and
i i i thought it was nice i thought john
batiste
uh uh was the kind of the hero
of it and also even things like i have
trombone friends who were talking on
facebook how
even when the girl plays in the
stairwell that is exactly
how those notes would sound in those
slide positions like
all of that was mocapped accurately um
and and they really thought okay we're
doing a movie because that's so often
overlooked like so
same thing with with queen's gambit on
andrea from
ready at dawn who's a giant chess nerd
was going on and on and on and on to me
about how
every game she plays in queen's gambit
is a hundred percent realistic there's
no movie magic anywhere they had like
um um gary kasparov you know
consulting on it saying you know if she
made this move that
she would have lost like she has to make
this but it's like there's no [ __ ]
anywhere
in the chest even when it's a shot where
you can barely see the chess board
and it's like i admire the craft of
things that is movie magic by the way
that's that's true movie magic yeah
you're right yeah is going through the
effort and actually consulting on those
people
that's the james cameron like on titanic
the [ __ ] nails they would have used
on the deck board better be accurate to
what they would have used
my final comment as i must go
is as we close out this year
i realized oh yeah
minus the the you're introducing the
year late into the year
minus the uh the drugs
the death the uh
being gay and the incredible voice i've
almost made the transition to george
michael
like that's the hair and the beard well
so the end of that sentence
is a giant question mark yeah i'm going
wham look at this
it's been it's been inevitable for a
long time yeah i guess dude i love
george michael man
hmm i guess we talk about
um something that i really enjoyed and
have
shockingly few criticisms of if none of
the ted lissa
i watched the whole thing on christmas
day and this podcast perfect
um absolutely loved it it's so obviously
being focused on premier league football
man maybe meant that i would have
more no i've heard actually i've had
friends who
say that they don't give a [ __ ] about
any of that and they still loved it
i adored it it's so positive and
uplifting and really funny there's
several jokes that i'm repeating now
just because i thought it was so
charming like just
absolutely adored it highly recommended
it i we watched uh
flight attendant and i just don't
recommend it
it's it's uh i've heard it was good the
the
the writing isn't as strong as the
premise in my opinion
uh but now we're watching the undoing
which is nicole kidman and man
it's good for the first few episodes how
far in are you i i think we're in
episode three it's not
it's not she is not liking it i
i like hugh grant um
i just every time i look at nicole
kidman
she looks like gloria swanson she's just
wow doing this whole thing and i usually
think she's a great actress
i i think that she has been i haven't
seen her anything recently i didn't
watch what was the movie
or the show that she's on the hbo um
she's in the hours
the liars
whatever the [ __ ] and i think she's
really dylan
i think it's big little lies one of the
chris's speaking of which
uh quick takes on wonder woman did you
guys watch it
i haven't watched it not out here yeah
can't get it here
i'm the only one i'm the only only one
who watches or whatever i did i did i
did wonder woman in seoul as a double
feature on christmas day
it was very american of me what's it
like what did you think it's got mixed
reviews right wonder woman it it
deserves the mixed reviews the thing
that i
the thing that i like about it is
that it's just so unapologetically what
it is
it's like you know and hans honestly han
zimmer is a big part of that because the
score
it couldn't be more opposite of all of
his other dc you think of all the other
scores he's done with
you know the batman versus superman
and uh the dark knight trilogy and you
know just the king of like dark brooding
this is this is full richard donner
bright shiny optimism and the movie
announces
towards the shazam end of things or
absolutely yes
absolutely yes including the fact that
it's a movie called wonder woman 1984
that takes place in 1984 that doesn't in
no way the
expected synth wave it is a it is a big
orchestral melodic which is ironically
what the 80s were full of
uh because of the popularity of star
wars and indiana jones and stuff there
was a huge surge of orchestral scores in
the 80s even though we think of it as
the era of synth wave
hans is channeling that full-on and and
he's done that before it kind of to me
at the whole time i said this sounds so
much like backdraft like it just
it he's done those scores in the past
and
he's basically he on behalf of patty
jenkins is screaming at you
take everything with just this full
popcorn don't
overthink any of this because the movie
falls apart instantly if you give it
a half seconds thought we're just here
to be as rollercoastery and popcorny as
possible it's cheesy it's ridiculous
it's loaded with plot holes and
contrivances and things that if you give
them
one seconds thought you're like wait now
that's actually quite [ __ ] up
or that's really stupid uh and but the
movie is just screaming at you we know
we know
don't worry about it and i i feel like
it just
by the skin of its teeth it stuck that
landing for me
and if it if it hadn't declared what it
was so much i would have been like this
is a pile this is a garbage
just a dumpster fire it sounds like
carrie will love it that's that's
yeah it was fun you know it was one of
those
it was it was i just haven't yeah i
really haven't wanted to devote the time
to something that's not going to be like
you will lose nothing in your life by
not that that's the thing
that's kind of the alternate that's the
flip of of what i'm
saying my last comment that i'm gonna
shut up is that i
also have to say i really really am on
board
with some very small caveats with where
mandalorian
has gone in season two next week
i would be interested to see what you
have to say troy because one of the the
things that has annoyed me the most
about mandalorian season two is the
performances like so consistently just
being like
oh stop doing so much with your face
well first i mean the first season was
that bad too i'm curious because this is
the uh pedro pascal
was actually supposed to be on set this
season as i understand
so i'm curious if that's true because he
wasn't for last season
yeah uh yes yes
you shall see it's a voice-over gig well
that was was the first one
yeah i know exactly it's funny i also
just don't know how that
i don't know what they call it that deep
fake how that was that bad
but okay
all right uh judge all things we're
saying yeah let's wrap it up
uh mike did you have did you have
anything that you wanted to to
that you enjoyed really recommend oprah
din
i finally got to playing over dinner
it's just it's blowing my mind it's just
pope that's possibly the best game i've
played in 10 years
i love it yeah yeah we we played it we
we started playing at like 6 p.m
played it six hours that night went to
bed got up first thing the next day
finished it in like four
pc what'd you play it on we had it on
the playstation just
in the yeah me on me on the controls but
it was it's a
best couples game ever just really good
kind of back and forth
chatting things through figuring it out
one person controller it was
genuinely great i love maybe really
that's the next one we've got downloaded
because i was saying this is someone
they suggested out of wild so i'm gonna
i missed that one because i i played out
a world without a while so
it's fantastic
i was like this why is everyone talking
about this well i like both games
this was great i like profless uh i'm
gonna finish playing the pathless what
else
i do need to finish playing the pathless
i've been going back and forth between
that and miles morales
nice i was saving that for ps5 is that
one i should just play
uh i would i would say on ps5 it's very
pretty photo mode it's gorgeous yeah
uh full disclosure i work for sony
interactive entertainment thank you
all right all right well happy new year
everyone we will see you next week